There's a really exciting thing in this books.
Something that I never thought I would ever see. So we look inside.
Okay.
So we'll, you can see straight away that it's black, the,
the outside is just some perspex lucites as you call it in
American, which is holding this black piece inside. And it's the black piece.
That's exciting. If you look at it a bit more,
you can probably guess that it's carbon. And if you know about carbon,
you can probably guess that it's graphite because it's obviously not diamond.
This is a piece of graphite from the world's very first
nuclear reactor that was built under the sports stadium
at stake field in Chicago, in the United States,
and went operational, went critical for the first time.
On the 2nd of December, 1942.
Think back from moments in the early 1940s,
there was a race to try and build an atom bomb and to try and
demonstrate that nuclear reactors could work.
That uranium atoms could be split by neutrons.
And when they split, they would emit more neutrons.
So the number of neutrons would build up and up and up and eventually
could lead to an explosion.
[Inaudible].
The famous physicist in Ricoh family,
who was at that time, working in Chicago,
built a so-called nuclear pile.
It was literally a pile of graphite blocks like this
with uranium oxide and uranium metal,
about five tons in all distributed within it.
So I don't have a very good model,
but this will have to do
the reactor was not round,
but with square and while they were building it,
they didn't want it to start reacting.
So they put into it control rods,
which could absorb neutrons.
They used a mixture of cadmium, indium, and silver.
The reason they chose silver was because silver can absorb neutrons and become
radioactive. So it connect rather like a neutron meter.
So once they had finished building this reactor,
they then started gently removing the roads.
And when they got the last road out,
suddenly the number of neutrons being emitted went up and up
and up and they left it running, I think for 28 minutes.
And then they put the rods in back in again to cool it down
because they built this reactor with no shielding
with no cooling and in the middle of a really densely
populated area of the States. So if it's a blown up,
it would have been serious. The reactor ran for quite a short time,
a few months,
and then was moved to outside Chicago onto the
site of what later became the so-called Argonne national lab.
And in February,
I visited the algo national lab with the UK ministry of
science, David Willets,
and he was leading the delegation and to
commemorate his visit, he was given this piece of graphite.
You can imagine how I felt this is something I really
liked to have had I go to nice pen,
but I much rather have had the piece of graphite,
but he did say that I could borrow it to make a video. Of course,
Brady wasn't on the trip with me.
So I made the couple of not very good home videos myself.
So you can see the minister talking actually mentioning this
present that he was given.
I was presented with a small piece of the graphite from that original
nuclear reactor, which is a very special gift that I will treasure.
I also went to visit the Henry Moore sculpture that has been built on the
site of where the nuclear reactor was originally built.
Unfortunately, they've built libraries and things around it.
So it doesn't really give you much idea of the sports field.
And there was a lot of snow there as well, and it was very cold.
I think that it is extremely interesting
that this graphite has been preserved.
And I think at the time it was quite hard to get high enough purity
graphite in that sort of quantity, many, many tons,
but you can see my reactors already collapsed.
Um, I think we should move it to the outside before it blows up.
This piece of graphites is really
symbolic of the whole nuclear age.
And it was the start, not only of the development of nuclear weapons,
but of the nuclear power stations,
which now supply a large proportion of the electricity in many
countries across the world,
nuclear reactors still have problems in the sense that there
is no elegant solution of what to do with the radioactive waste
that is produced by the reactors. As time goes on,
people develop number of technologies,
which will put the radioactive material into glass
separates off the useful components you will have seen.
We visited the national nuclear laboratory,
where they had separated off I'm a risk Siham,
which can be used for smoke detectors and things like that.
Plutonium can be used to power satellites.
There are all sorts of very useful applications for small amounts of
this material.
I sometimes wondered whether this will be radioactive,
but carbon is particularly useful
for nuclear reactors because it does not easily become radioactive.
It is in the thick layer of plastic.
So unless it was contaminated from some other radioactive
source, I think it's unlikely. This will be radioactive,
but perhaps we lost my colleague Steve,
little to give it a quick check just in case before we give it back to the
minister. Well,
then we can decide it's we can be sure it will be safe to give it back to the
minister. Are you going to give it back to him? Do you think you'll notice? Um,
well I saw him yesterday at another meeting in London
and his assistant of clad where it was.
So I think I'm going to have to give it back,
but he may see the video and relent.